hey you guys should try some
DMT sexy Reds uh when's the show when's
the show of October October October 17th
and 18th you guys are opening for sexy
red never leave a a lighter around Kyle
he'll steal it and break it
um uh you guys have the number five song
in New York City Nicki Minaj said hi to
you but not to them are you dumb n
definitely
said hey hey the turn around like Hey
Y'all doesn't count he got the
handshake I was on her radio like for me
so did she shake your hand game what you
I had aown Li I just told you the
conversation he had a
conversation press me [__] I could
never be pressed [__] G [__] is you
talking
about going Li
Queen She deaded
bro she said so she turned around she's
like hey um what are you doing what's
your name she's like K rich like um yeah
I don't really want no phones behind me
you know people get weird and stuff he's
like yeah I'm sorry you had more of a
too Brad and say I'm
sorry are you dumb I said I said feel me
I understand my fault gangster is
different my fault yeah it's a
sorry we both is not the same that's
literally I'm sorry so you you talk to
her more than anybody you just got a
high no T why did you talk to her he
made me talk to I was really like she
was like I'm like yeah I S just when I'm
the reason she
played you got to play our [__] you got
to play like number one song like I
screens wow she play
it that's
sick legendary all right guys
well hopefully the song she gets on the
remix or something no y n that's howb me
label mates stop Hing label
mate isn't that Me Drake's your label
mate huh yeah there you guys I mean you
guys are on universal you guys got all
Republic's got all the [__] we all
winning man [__] the weekends your
label mate post Malone post Malone
Taylor Swift your label mate is yeah
yeah that's pretty Grande too hey she
just had to pay her ex-husband $11.25
million in a divorce settlement Ariana
Grande it was that serious let this
fellas be a lesson y'all marry up marry
up city boy up city boy up let's go all
right that's how we're ending the
interview uh City boys up city boys up
city boys up man th points my S is City
boys up 1.25 million City Boys [__] off
of a [__] two-year marriage good for
him any the marriage he did shout out to
let me not even well I'm going to let
you get to your phone I appreciate y'all
pulling up man
boom what's going on man I want to shout
out to our family a hardan for
presenting to you another interview all
right there's another interview coming
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day shout out to harden though if you're
in Las Vegas man the number one
dispensary in the world there are family
there are brothers there are [__]
dogs over there man we love them they
always are taking care of us and they'll
take care of you if you go to harden in
Vegas let's say you're Landing in Vegas
you're going to go watch the Raiders
you're going to go watch a Vegas show
whatever get in that taxi tell them
straight up take me to harden when you
get to harden they going get you hooked
up with the craziest uh just variety and
selection of Premium cannabis on the
planet and if you tell them you heard
about us on the on on the bootleg Kev
show you say hey uh Harden I heard about
y'all on the bootleg C podcast they're
gonna take care of y'all all right so go
follow him Hardin Las Vegas on all
social media and check them out Hardin
vegas.com what's up Harden